avant la catastrophe par 12h15 aux
cardinaux nommés par le pape un mal
mystérieux de la maternité baudelocque
les messins sexting une enquête
la transatlantique en double c'est parti
retour à lorient dans un foyer pour les
plus rapides soit 38 wali la route des
bermudes avec une demi heure de retard
ou l'avait d'ailleurs suivi en direct
dans votre journal de prévert c'est en
effet à 13h30 exactement quelle est ta
ble ment commencé la première
transatlantique à 2 lorient les berner
les berniques lorient le dossier était
parfaite puisque les rafales atteignant
80 km/heure et les 38 voiliers ont donc
mis le cap la large des risques à
l'échelle ines qui les grands battus de
la route du rhum s'est rapidement porté
en tête
chaque voilier est parfaitement
localisés grâce à des signaux
électroniques relayée par satellite
parmi les produits voilier qu'il en ait
pas dans le suivant plus
particulièrement la course s'est jouée
de manier journalistes à terre à l'aide
d'une radio spéciale mais très longue
portée stéphane magnier loup tiendra
tiendra informé quotidiennement du
déroulement voici donc la première
liaison avec notre envoyé spécial sur
cette transat et de depuis l'étape on
dirait que ce n'est pas nous entendre
le premier
le collège 2015
chaleureux et un ami de jean paul
l'audience de roger etchegaray départ
des frontières françaises car il occupe
lui devant la présidence du conseil
européen avec ce titre il voyage vous
est pris de position sur le racisme le
quercy billets dab de mater dans son
journal lui valent une large popularité
l'archevêque de marseille est un homme
ouvert je ne ferme la porte à personne
ne lui a pas donné le chapeau de
cardinal
parce que le vatican reproché à l'époque
la france la loi sur l'avortement une
certaine tiédeur de l'épiscopat français
et les propos mal interprétés sur
l'éthique sexuelle par le crayon
d'aujourd'hui cardinal jean paul ii
entend signifier qu'il faut utiliser
plus largement les compétences de
l'évêque de marseille le manifeste la
confiance pour l'église catholique de
france
tu voudrais plus jean paul ii poursuit
l'internationalisation du collège des
cardinaux ils sont neufs qui devraient
contribuer à plus ou moins brève
échéance à renouveler efficacement le
fonctionnement de la curie bientôt
l'initiative empêcher
là
les internationaux
georges
si l'euro pénaliser des olympiades les
faits le chef de l'état serait
d'ailleurs rien à la radio et à la
télévision
la france alors de laura la campagne
précédente
l'europe également sociales et travail
la moitié les marcheurs de paris arrive
et pourtant autant de noms que de panis
mans